good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy
Tuesday
hi I was going to say hope everyone's
having a great day I'm so excited I said
I started to say a bunch of different
things but hope everyone's having a
great day I'm so excited to be sitting
down with my girl Jax hey
lard hey jard how you by the way I'm
lard your J Rule totally I'm doing well
a lot going on I can't believe it's only
Tuesday thanks for ing me I feel like
yesterday was just jam-packed also my
mind is a little bit elsewhere right now
because I'm reading the book for the
redheads called strange Sally Diamond
have you heard about it I saw it on
another redheads Instagram story Rebecca
Rittenberg uh excuse me mince uh saying
that it was amazing it's really good but
like when add it to your list what's it
called strange Sally
Diamond it's very much like pulls you in
and it's hard to mentally be elsewhere
while I'm in the middle of it yeah
that's a good book so it's very good
we're recording tomorrow and I'll be
finished with the book sometime today
and 384 Pages I'm in I'm very much like
in the heads space of the book book of
course I'll be getting out of it in two
seconds once we start talking about
whatever nonsense is on Deck today but
that's kind of where I'm at love that
that's always like a good sign of a good
book that like you literally like are in
that Universe like you dream about the
book yeah but this isn't really a book
like you want to be dreaming about it's
a little spooky scary skeletons but the
way that it's written makes it takes The
Spook out of it a little bit well I'm
going to read it but next up on my list
is um tattooist of asit like I've never
read it and it's like
classic classic book for the girlies you
know the girlies love that book so
actually what was so exciting about that
is that when we were on our trip the
house that we were staying in had like a
bunch of bookshelves and they had like
some pretty good books on it and they
had the tattooist of outfits so I just
took it but I put a book back I put this
book that I read that you had bought me
from the local bookstore called the uh
the other half yeah which was it was
fine I put that on the the shelf and
took tatsh ofas Rich do you think that's
okay I do it's in exchange though I will
say their books they didn't have a lot
it was just like one bookshelf but the
books that I had read that were on the
Shelf were all Fire books so it made me
feel like every other book that they had
that I hadn't read I would also really
like cuz every book that they had that I
had read is was a five-star book and
that's like how rental houses work like
hotels do that too right they have like
bookshelves where it's like the honor
System you give and take it's such a
cute idea they didn't say that that's
how this house was working and I don't
think it was cuz clearly the same person
had chosen all of these books and I
don't think the tattoist of a schwitz
and the other half are congruous it's
not an equal trade but it's okay sure
also technically tattooist of asit is
shorter and it was paperback and yours
was longer and hard cover so you gave
them a more expensive book so true the
monetary value cannot be overlooked here
the fiscal side of things yes but the
emotional value the the mental yeah
value but also the book I took it like
it's read like it's worn it's scratched
it's you know the pages are crinkled
like somebody lived and loved this book
and now it's time to pass it on yeah
yeah I need to pick I have the next
choice for the redheads but I'm so out
of the loop on reading right now like
right now I just read whatever the
redheads book is and then maybe like one
other book during the month of something
that I've seen that I like but I have
like no idea what's popping I need to do
a little bit of research I was actually
maybe going to ask you for a
recommendation
me cuz you just read like 10 books
anything in there that we should be
reading for the red but you have to give
me like guidance like what five star
book five star book I read two
unbelievable Thrillers
share don't let her stay and behind
closed doors I think I would select
behind closed doors is don't let her
stay by Peter Weber's mom don't let her
go go no very close though those are the
two from my trip that were probably
or if you I know you guys just did a
celebrity Memoir but not enough people
are talking about mik the situations
book I keep trying to get people to read
it it sounds so silly like on the
service like Mike The Situation wrote A
Memoir it's
incredible perhaps though we just did a
memoir and I just read Elon so I'm ready
for some fiction you said what was the
other book don't let her stay
and uh behind closed
doors I don't know if I want like a
thriller thriller cuz that's always like
a good
book you know it's really safe but it's
not like the best for a book club like
CU there's that that much themes and
overarching messaging to discuss it's
just like were you spooked or no yeah no
like did you guess the plot or did you
not were you spooked yes or no are you
still texting yes or no I love
that that's come back into the four this
week that's the thing about the toast
and about just like pop culture in
general it's like you really never know
what's going
to hit you you and when and when is the
bigger question cuz that hit us that hit
us six years ago ago I was thinking this
in the cab yesterday of something we've
been saying recently that's like so
random wait it just give me two
seconds
okay I don't know it's like not even
close to coming to me okay but it'll
come to me what was the thought you were
thinking something you were saying is so
Random like this like phrase we've been
using
like it's so random and so not even
recent but we've been saying it so much
recently we need of the
week no no it was like a pop culture
thing very similar to are you still
texting okay I'm sure we'll come
back around to it whatever um we've got
a great show today we've got stories
we've got things in which to discuss oh
I went to the Mean Girls movie premiere
last night you know it's a story so
maybe you could share your personal yeah
experience in the story and that would
kind of add value to the stories cuz
it's like oh we had a reporter on the
ground so I'll just shut the up is
what you want me to say I would say
table it is what I would say tableit SL
shut the up I would never tell you
to do that because I know you
couldn't they try they try and they try
and they try do they even try to get me
to shut the up it's a futile effort
but I can't like some things in life are
just guaranteed you know and me not
shutting the up is one of them
death taxes and tury talking
title totally death taxes and tury
talking because we're always talking
about taxes on this show hate I don't
feel like we talk about death that much
because we could try to be positive
Queens but it is just a natural part of
life yeah it's a great equalizer it it
that's my favorite thing to say by the
way that death is the great equalizer oh
I just like the term the great equalizer
I feel like there are a couple things
that are what else like not to go there
but
pooping we all do it we're all screaming
crying throwing up screaming for help
naked on the toilet not even that but
like Everybody Poops yeah we and
everybody has like those days where they
just have like really bad gas and their
farts like smell kind of different you
know are you having one of those days I
actually was having them in uh Utah on
our trip because something like the
altitude they say gives you gaset called
the altitudes but like mine we a
different breed in terms of fragrance I
have like a crazy question I hate
talking about flatulence you know I do
but I this question is something that
I've been wondering a little bit it's
like people who live in the altitude
they get adjusted they adjust and when
they come to like sea level when they
come to New York I don't think so are
there farts different no it's a good
question if you live in like Colorado
Utah any like mountainous area drop a
comment what is your flatulence like
when you hit the states that aren't like
turn when you hit sea level sea level
and then then do you notice when you go
back home like things are a little crazy
right or does it get Crazy For You at
sea level
yeah are we just like living inverse
experiences or you don't have these
problems let us
know oh speaking of let us know the
community is divided is divided on our
conversation from yesterday which you
know what makes sense because like we're
too rational people like we don't just
say crazy things and we were so divided
if I saw something and you saw something
and we both really believe that we saw
something it makes sense that fellow
rational people would be split as well
we didn't do a poll but if we had done a
poll like it was legit 5050 in terms of
comments of people who agreed with me
and people who agreed with you about
whether or not Taylor Swift was upset by
the comment and I'm okay with that like
I understand why everybody thought
something but I know that I saw
something and I'm I stand even more and
I read everyone's comments like and
everyone who claimed that Taylor was mad
and their reasoning like made me even
more fervent in my belief that she
wasn't mad I am still fervent in mine
but are you seeing that the the the
backlash from Joe koi's monologue is
like that he offended Taylor Swift like
I saw Paparazzi pictures Joe koi out and
about you know uh not bothered by Taylor
Swift drama like it's all about Joe vers
Taylor Joe vers Taylor and Joe vers
Barbie I I didn't no I didn't even see
Joe vers Barbie by the way that's why I
brought it up yesterday because I feel
like it really like makes Taylor like
like thinking that she's mad and I
really don't think that she's mad I feel
like it makes her look bad it's like you
go to an award show and part of it is
like there's a monologue and you're
going to be poked fun at and as long as
it's in good fun and it's not means
spirited which it wasn't it's okay so
now it's like Taylor was offended when I
don't think that she was I feel like
it's making her look bad and theft the
Swift is getting mad on her behalf and
like canceling Jo Koy like calm down it
does make her look bad if she was mad
about the comment because it wasn't
offensive it was stupid and loow hanging
fruit but it wasn't like mean or below
the belt or anything like that and I'm
telling you I like she's not mad like I
I just I know she's
not well we're not going to relitigate
it and we feel how we feel and now we
know how everyone else feels and I guess
it's just kind of a great mystery yeah
and like this is just is one of those
situations where it would be so
nice if she could just like you know
send a tweet but even if she sent a
tweet at this point say she was mad when
it came out and then she sees that being
mad about it was you know a bad look she
could send a tweet and say no I wasn't
mad I was like play like we we'll still
never know we'll still never know how
she felt in the moment lie girly lie
we'll never know wait also did you make
it a story that TMZ caught up with
Timothy shalamay and he had something to
say no I didn't but I was looking for a
f story that I was going to bring during
the ad break so just saw it on Tik Tok
on my way uh to the toast so that's
perfect for you oh thank you so much now
the stories are complete um what else
did I want to talk
about you know I've I've been thinking
about this thesis a lot and I didn't
want to share it on the toes till it was
like fully formed is it formed no but I
feel like with all the talk about like
Taylor and the Barbie movie like I want
to talk about it okay so I'm I'm seeing
this sort of thing being said a lot I
think people have been saying it for
many years I find myself saying it
sometimes when it's like when we're
criticizing a woman it's like you know
well they would never criticize a man
for this and it's so true um and I saw
this Tik Tok of an in a really old
interview that Britney brosi did she's
a podcaster Tik tocker very funny girl
on Tik Tok I think actually think you
would really like her um and she was
talking about how like she can't get
away with like half the that like
her male comrades can't can get away
with like and I think she was like
talking a lot about like the theovon
types you know and it's so true it's
like you know if she got cancelled like
it would take her three times as long to
bounce back as it would just like a male
counterpart of hers and it's so true
like women can't can't get like can't
get away with anything and and I love
this conversation but I feel like a
vital part of this conversation is
missing and the part of the conversation
is like someone like Theo Von can say
something insane like maybe there's like
a little conversation backlash about it
but it's not going to really derail his
career and it's not going to
you know affect him in a real major way
and the reason for that and I think a
lot of people what we need to really
understand about this part of the
conversation is like that's happening is
because majority of the ofans fans are
me are men yeah that's what I was going
to say yeah it's a part of the conver
when when people say like uh this would
never happen to a man I think the part
of the conversation they're leaving out
that is of utmost importance is that it
would never happen to a man because
let's say a man is listening to this
podcast and a man hears something maybe
he doesn't like or he doesn't agree with
or he thinks it's a little nuts what's a
man going to do do he's either going to
turn it off or he's just going to keep
listening and move on with his life go
to work you know do what do what men do
I don't know what they do when a woman
listens to a podcast and hears something
that she doesn't like what does she do
does she turn it off no nine times out
of 10 she's going to make it her mission
to tear this person down the woman who
said that thing MH so we need to start
including like we need to start taking
responsibility for like what so why why
would this not happen to a man because
men male audiences are just different
like if they they're not they're not
galvanized they're not going to start
petitions like they're not motivated in
that way yeah that's not their behavior
typically online and maybe it's not
necessarily always a gender thing but I
think you just have to ask the question
of like who is this person's audience
and also like are they conditioned to
hearing things that they find offensive
but if you like build an audience while
being like so P that's true also true
and then you want to go off the rails a
little bit like that audience be like
hey hey what are you doing like that's
not who we are but if you from day one
like you are yourself and you cultivate
an audience who's used to hearing
outlandish things it doesn't make as
much noise when you do something that's
true also like how you've acted up until
this point like you're conditioning your
audience to be receptive to crazy things
or not crazy things that's very true
also I just thought it was really I do
think yeah like the women are doing the
counselling right right so it's like the
women are out here being like well this
would never happened to a man but the
women are also responsible for that sort
of Fallout they are yeah so it needed to
be said yeah I didn't know that was like
a big conversation that's happening no
it's it's people always are just saying
would never happened to a woman and it's
so true and then recently I started
thinking I'm like well why why would it
never happen to a it's Case by case you
need to give me like the exact people
and their audiences I'm not thinking
about exact people I'm just thinking
about the culture in general yeah but
when we think about like those men who
it wouldn't happen to it's like yeah
because they sent their career is like
being Brash and maybe that's why they're
not somewhere else maybe they be even
further but instead they're doing what
they're doing and they found an audience
of people who will tolerate it yeah
totally well thank you for that thought
starter on this Tuesday morning just
always wanting to you know be moving the
needle yeah I mean that doesn't bode
well for us because we have an all
female audience no I know and I'm not
like blaming the toasters I'm just like
I'm talking about but I actually think
we're a great example of like uh uh at
one point having had an audience of
sensitivo sens and then you have to
cultivate the audience you wish to see
in the world yeah totally so I don't
it's not always just because of your
chromosomes no that's true also but I
think something uh like a relevant uh
example is like what what Matt re is
doing yeah poorly yeah but it's like is
there an example of a women's brand mhm
that has that sort of crazy crude Brash
humor with female audience that
tolerates it like I'm sure there are
shows that exist maybe on a small level
but not on a big level like not in like
the top 50 podcast right like no T is it
us are we the
Renegades like no we're not even that
crazy we sit and talk about Taylor Swift
all day like we're not even that crazy
but no there's not there's not to answer
your question and that's the question I
think why where are
they what I'll tell you where they are
like they can't they can't do it they
get destroyed before they reach any sort
of level of success because women are
the are the counsellors of the internet
like female consumers are the ones you
know emailing Brands be like you're
supporting a podcast I one time said
this like have you seen this tweet like
women are the one doing that men are not
doing that wow they can't get out of the
gate it it makes me want to do something
crazy I know just for the sake of like
being that person just to say that we
can yeah no I'm telling you I'm on to
something with this thesis I think we
it's like still a work in progress and I
would love to hear anyone's thoughts but
like and maybe we're forgetting someone
who's like a major female show that like
says something crazy no I think there's
a lot of female shows that
like not aren't crazy but like toe the
line you know are honest but not
offensive
mhm like I feel like Heather
McDonald no she's not even remotely
controversial yeah like and the fact
that that we're thinking like theovon
and Heather McDonald like the two
couldn't be on more different planets
yeah no but there's no
like com Netflix special that's like the
female like Ricky Jas or Dave Chappelle
no no no exactly and that's literally
the point of what I'm saying so it's
like yeah a woman can never get away
with this but why because of women and
it's like and who has
tried that's like the last one to really
ever do it like is Joan
Roseanne Roseanne kind of like Kathy
Griffin but not really not really yeah
there's
not and and we we need to ask ourselves
why we need never stop asking why yeah I
feel like we're getting to the root of
something here I what it is it's a whip
a work in progress okay thesis well
again thank you for that thought starter
you're welcome I haven't really question
gender Dynamics on the internet in a
while oh my God it's literally all I
think about that's funny oh and you know
what else made me think about this oh
I'm so glad you just brought that up
really what was the Catalyst for this
thesis is because when Ben first started
his podcast with Josh I would listen to
every single episode because Ben is not
Ben doesn't understand the internet like
Ben's just a normal guy who like has
thoughts and doesn't realize like it
could be problematic so I would like
listen to every episode I was so
petrified for Ben I'm like you can't say
this you can't say that and you know
Josh is in the media and Josh like you
know is very um media trained and
sensitive and he's smart and he
understands like the way the world works
so he wouldn't ever say or put anything
out there and I very slowly stopped
listening to their episodes cuz I'm like
I can't listen to every single and edit
every single one of their episodes for
them like another two a week I'm like
please like you're on your own you're
grown up I gave you the tools here what
you do with them is up to you and I
would like tune into episodes like
months later and they would be saying
like kind of kind of crazy
stuff
nothing nothing and I'm like oh that's
interesting that's really what made me
start the the Journey
of of this thesis and this thought
process and this line of thinking got it
is there anything you want to do about
it no no no I'm just I want to like I
think we should all be aware like the
next time you're a woman and who says
something like well this would never
happen to a man I want you to sit back
and think like are you a woman who has
torn down another woman
for doing something that you don't like
or that you don't agree with cuz you are
the problem
yeah I don't do that like I don't tear
down other women I'm not the
problem I don't email Brands no I don't
email Brands even if there's a woman out
there who I think is like vile who I
hate like okay I'll just hate her like
from the comfort of my own bedroom I'm
not going to like write a essay about it
right or like and they have like a brand
like and that brand is platforming
someone who is vile and I hate like okay
I just won't shop the brand
right I'm not going to like start a
whole thing
yeah okay well let's get into the
stories yeah without further ad do here
are the stories that you do do need to
know on this Tuesday and the stories
that you do need to know on this Tuesday
are brought to you by game time you
shouldn't have to worry about when to
buy tickets for your next big event game
time is the fast and easy way to buy
tickets for all the sports music comedy
theater everything near you they have
killer last minute deals they have Allin
pricing and views from your seat plus
their best price guante game time takes
the guesswork out of buying tickets so
game time is the only ticketing app that
gives you complete peace of mind with
your purchase see the view from your
seat before you buy so you know exactly
what to expect when you arrive all in
pricing shows your total upfront so you
know you're getting a great deal before
you check out buy tickets in seconds
with two Taps it's really just like the
best app on the planet really what I
like about it most is like when you buy
tickets especially like buying from like
secondhand places these days you'll buy
find a ticket that's say like $100 then
by the time you check Che out it's
almost double the price with all the
fees and all the things they just like
hide from you not with game time their
pricing is all in so what you see is
what you're paying for they also have
deals on tickets right up to start right
up to the start of the event even an
hour after it starts it's the place to
find last minute seats you can find
exclusive Flash Deals sponsor tickets
for football basketball baseball
concerts comedy theater and more the
game time guarantee means you'll always
get the best price and if you find
tickets in the same section in row for
Less game time will credit you 110% of
the difference take the guest work out
of buying tickets with game time
download the game time app create an
account and use code toast for $20 off
your first purchase terms apply again
create an account redeem code toast
to for $20 off download game time today
last minute tickets lowest price guadan
today's episode is also brought to you
by stamps.com a new year is full of
surprises but one thing that is
predictable is that postage will postage
costs will go up again in 2024
stamps.com is giving you crazy discounts
up to 89% off USPS and UPS services so
your business will barely notice the
change stamps.com has been helping
businesses Like Yours save time and
money for over 25 years it's your own
personal post office wherever you are
with stamps.com all you need is a
computer and a printer they'll even send
you a free scale so you have to take so
you'll have everything you need to get
started you can take care of orders on
the go with the stamps.com mobile app if
you need a package pickup you can easily
schedule it through stamps.com in the
dashboard and if you sell products
online stamps.com seemlessly connects
with every major Marketplace and
shopping cart they have crazy discounts
and premium supplies at your fingertips
so if you're running low you can order
shipping and mailing supplies like
labels even printers from their supply
store you're getting huge carrier
discounts which is are up to 89% off
USPS and UPS rates to help your bottom
line plus stamps.com automatically tells
you your cheapest and fastest shipping
options your postage partner for over 25
years is stamps.com they've been
indispensable for over a million
businesses where you can get access to
the USPS and UPS services that you need
right from the palm of your hand anytime
day or night no lines no traffic no
waving take a chunk out of your mailing
and shipping cost this year with
stamps.com sign up with promo code toast
for a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and a
free digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts are required
just go to stamps.com Click the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and enter code toast that's t o a
s thank you la you're welcome J our
first story The saga continues speaking
of a Jah and an a who are feuding Jimmy
Kimmel calls on Aaron Rogers to
apologize for his Epstein comments
during a scorching
monologue so Jimmy Kimel delivered a
monologue on his show going in on Aaron
roders for what he said about the list
he said quote he said I was hoping it
wouldn't come out and that he was going
to pop a bottle of something to
celebrate when he did and then it did
come out and of course my name wasn't on
it and isn't on it and won't ever be on
he clarified that he didn't know Jeffrey
epsteam claiming they never even met he
said I'm not on the list I was not on a
plane or an island or anything ever I
suggested that if Aaron wanted to make
false and very damaging statements like
that we should do it in court so that he
can share his proof with the judge so
Jimmy said that Aaron may have gone
after him for criticizing Aaron in the
past and while Jimmy believes that
athletes have every right to discuss
current events he said there's a
difference between trash talk and
spreading
disinformation so I watch this 10-minute
thing okay eight minutes okay and I will
I will I want to give credit to Jimmy
Kimmel because he did admit that he
started this like he and he actually ran
the clip of what he had said that really
started this like random Feud because I
guess a lot of people are like how the
do these two even know each other
so respect there like I was just looking
up the original um Feud
starting comment what did he show he
didn't so he basically when he like had
first mentioned Aaron Rogers he
basically called him like dumb called
him
um what did he say was it the thing
about the vaccine say that again sofin
soft brain yeah it was about the vaccine
but then he like it wasn't even so much
about what Aaron had said about about
the vaccine it was like why we shouldn't
be trusting Aaron Rogers basically like
he's a like it was mean-spirited
like he like he was poking he was poking
the bear the heal myself with crystals
thing did he say that wasn't included in
the clip okay okay however so honestly
respect for owning the fact that you
started this like this is why we're
talking about you too and that's why
this is going on now I do feel as though
given this you know Feud Jimmy Kimmel
has been Vindicated everyone knows that
his name was not on the list
jimmmy Kimmel is in an interesting spot
and I really feel like at this point in
at this juncture Jimmy kiml should shut
the up because like for a and we
forget because nobody watches the Jimmy
Kimmel show like night after night but
people forget that like Jimmy Kimmel
gets on his show and for the first 15
minutes like he just makes fun of people
and it's yeah it's in good fun y y but
like he makes fun of people on this huge
Network on this huge platform and
there's really never any
like backlash or kind of Fallout from
that mostly because I don't think really
anyone watches to show but like that's
what you do for a living and like
somebody said something about you one
time and like you're making a federal
case out of it like grow up yeah like
come on and I don't know it's like not a
good look like and it's mostly because
like these two couldn't be more
different politically but like it's just
not a good look it's giving very much
like shut up and sing shut up and
dribble you know like oh like that Aaron
doesn't have a right to have an opinion
about things because he went to
Community College and he's an athlete it
was so like really condescending and
derogatory that whole Community College
thing yeah and very leest also Jimmy's
whole thing was like you know when we
make a mistake like we apologize and
that Aaron should apologize to him but I
also think if you look back at the
origin of their Feud and the whole Aaron
Rogers drama to begin with when he said
like he was immunized but he didn't have
the vaccine he had just had
covid oh I didn't know that that was a
thing okay say that again so when the
NFL was like mandating that players get
the vaccine and Aaron Rogers refused to
get it he said that he was already
immunized because he had already had Co
and he had natural immunity antibodies
and at the time that was not enough for
people and they wanted him to still get
the vaccine but we have since learned
that natural immunity is more
preventative against covid than the
vaccine was so he wasn't lying he wasn't
lying time has proven him to be right so
if I were Jimmy Kimmel I would stop
bringing up and if you want people to
apologize for when they were wrong well
Jimmy you were wrong about that no and
also like are we seriously talking about
Co right now like grow up like move on
have moved on like we have all blocked
out those horrendous years and the
people who were like pleasing
vaccinations should just like quietly
sit down totally and shut up and not
keep bringing it up because like you
were not right no 1,00% and your
behavior was wrong and Jimmy K's really
just like not in a position to be like
like the moral High Ground on like
talking when it's literally what you do
for a living you know like you poke fun
at so many people all the time and no
and then someone pokes fun at you and
it's like well it's not poking fun it's
disinformation it's like no like we're
taking this to court like calm down and
again he didn't say Jimmy's on the list
he said Jimmy will be nervous Jimmy
doesn't want the list to come out which
as we stated yesterday like of course
that's talking and it makes you
think oh Jimmy's on the list but it
could me other things in a court of law
and as we talked about last week 170
people were on the list or was it a
thousand there were no not even to say
on the list like it makes it seem like a
list and here are the pedophiles names
in the docks yeah right right right a
lot of those names were nothing Burgers
it was like did you meet this person no
okay but now their beonce and Jay-Z were
in the docks Kate Blanchett was in the
dock right Leonardo DiCaprio was in the
dock like just because you're in the
dock of course doesn't mean you're a
pedophile but now you know you can also
you know be on the list and be a
pedophile I just think that's worth
mentioning um but this Feud is just so
first of all r
second of all what I now that I've now
that I'm invested in this Feud and I've
learned all this information against my
will I've learned that Jimmy Kimmel
started
this Jimmy Kimmel really now that I'm
like thinking about Jimmy Kimmel and his
career and like you know his place in
culture really doesn't have a like to
stand on like to be mad at someone for
saying something on a show about him
when he gets up every day and like says
stuff about people on his show like
that's what he does for her living like
that would like it's
just it's just not right yeah
yeah it ain't so I don't know he's kind
of cementing the weenie of the week yeah
yeah if he let responds also to give
your entire monologue to like this one
throwaway comment that Aaron made and
you already like dispelled it on Twitter
and like went full force no Jackie I'm
telling you Jimmy Kimel has made this
such a big when the original sin of
Aaron roders was actually like he's been
vind ated Jackie we have
not spoken about Jimmy Kimmel like in
depth probably ever on this show I don't
think about Jimmy Kim I don't think most
people do he's just like kind of a
fixture in culture industry plant yeah
yeah industry plant so the fact that
this is such a big story is only because
Jimmy Kimmel responded have we ever like
who the hell cares Jimmy I mean Aaron
Rogers goes on the pat MCA show a 100
times a week like he's like they're
always just like talking about stuff it
never becomes newsworthy it wasn't even
newsworthy when he said it Jimmy Kimmel
responding made it newsworthy so now
we're all talking about Jimmy Kimmel and
pedophilia we weren't talking about it
before right and the documents came out
in Jimmy Kimmel wasn't on he could have
just let the evidence speak for itself
right but no now here we are like every
sentence is Jimmy Kimmel X pedophilia no
and we're Rel litigating the entire
fight and and looking back at the
origins and and Jimmy's not looking
great no he's not so he maybe now maybe
he'll stop but I don't know now does
Aaron say something right I honestly
think if if anyone can get this message
to Aaron like I think Aaron shouldn't
respond because like leaving Jimmy
Kimmel with this like dick hanging out
he did a 10-minute monologue on his like
major Network show about Aaron roders
and if Aaron Rogers just like doesn't
respond I I think that'll be for the
best I think he should respond and I I'm
not even going to tell him what to say
because I'm sure he has a fire flames
response on his own also Jimmy Kimel
ended his monologue with another joke
about like two A's cuz remember when he
tweeted about Aaron Rogers he called him
a like two A's in Aaron two A's
in like I actually thought that
was funny he did it again it's like okay
the one that that his grades in college
he got two A's and they were in were
only two A's on Aaron's report card and
they were both in his name he's
basically calling him dumb saying he
went to Community College and didn't
graduate college which is such a um
condescending and
bad look look like everything like it's
a Terri like it it was at the very top
of the monologue and after after like
after that I really wasn't going to be
on Jimmy Kimmel's side like I I listened
in good faith like I opened the
monologue
with open ears like to hear what he was
saying and he just he came off like a an
elitist yeah I look forward to a
response yeah we'll see The Saga is so
like so dumb and crazy yeah are you
ready for our next story someone else
who's responding oh my God yeah Timothy
shalamay oh says is there's no drama
between Kylie and Selena everyone's all
good so Timothy ran into TMZ out and
about in La as chy let us know he was
walking around Beverly Hills on Monday
night trying to lay low with his hood on
uh but a TMZ fotog spotted him and atted
to attempted to chat him up about all
things Golden Globe they asked if the
rumors that his girlfriend Kylie denied
Selena a photo of him and her were true
and after a lot of playful back and
forth he said it's BS so wait the crazy
thing about this video if you watch the
whole thing is that this photographer is
standing outside of a an institution
waiting for someone else she is waiting
for I think his name is ddg the guy that
Hal Bailey just had had a baby with so
she upon great Fortune this photographer
happens to be there at the same time
Timothy shalam is leaving this this
facility she cannot believe her luck she
starts chasing him down the street and
he's like how did you find me and she's
like oh my God I was waiting outside
this building for ddg he goes who is
that it's like the craziest Saga and she
keeps asking him questions about did you
know Kylie deny Selena a photo is there
any beef between Kylie and Selena and he
is not responding but eventually at the
very end of the video he said like this
whole thing when when asked the question
do Kylie and Selena have beef he said no
this is BS now I believe it's BS cuz I
don't believe Kylie would like deny a
photo like it's just weird especially in
like a public place where people could
see that however I think we're all
forgetting about eyebrow gate well I
just want to say one thing because we
had a lot of disagreements yesterday but
one thing that I'm now on your side on
is I had seen more of the video and I do
agree with you that Selena was telling
the girls that she asked to get a
picture with Timothy and Kylie said no
and then Kelly said with Timothy about a
picture and now even though he just
debunked it I believe more than ever
like there was a picture that was
attempted but I do think it was I don't
no I by the way what I said yesterday
was that Kelly Terry Terry speller
tell kry oh my
God Kelly sper teller 100% said with
Timothy of course but what about I don't
know what Selena said I think it was
about a picture but I don't think it was
like Selena wanted a selfie with Timothy
that Kylie said no to I think they she
wanted to take like a group picture with
the photographer because there were a
lot of pictures of Selena with
celebrities and I just want to say like
if Kylie Jenner hates Selena Gomez sorry
she has every right to based on eyelash
brow Haley Bieber gate and first of all
Haley Bieber is like a lifelong family
friend of the Kardashians and I'm sorry
like Selena Gomez has been horrible and
her she has like encouraged really sort
of toxic fan Behavior not helped really
at all I'm she is the villain of
haly's if they hate her sorry they're
allowed to and we're not taking a
picture with you no I completely agree
so that to me I understand why Selena
wanted a picture and by the way Selena
has never like outright done anything
like to be like haly so I could see
her going over there and being like
what's wrong like I didn't do anything
like let's take a picture of Kylie and
like literally eyebrow gate which was
less than a year ago which was so nuts
and really sent so much negativity and
toxicity and hatred towards Haley and
Kylie's way for no reason sorry
she has every right to say no yeah I
agree I would say same I don't think she
said no I just want to say oh I think
she did I think she did I think Kylie
wanted a picture with you know rainy day
in New York I mean Selena did and Kylie
would be in it because her and Timothy
are attached to the hip and it would be
a group photo and Kylie said no like I'm
not like that picture would be
everywhere that would hurt haly's
feelings that would like look like Kylie
endorses this beh no no no picture with
Timothy yeah no yeah no so Timothy
saying it's all Bs but he could be
saying that about like any part of the
beef no but he's going to protect in the
words of Gypsy Rose like that's his
Queen you know and she's just being
herself
and and like he's going to you know lie
and protect if that's the case and I
think that's fine yeah so obsessed with
those two but I have come to the
realization that that's what she was
saying Selena about picture oh so you're
you're fully believe yeah I'm not
totally convinced I I definitely think
they were talking about like
something with Kylie and Timothy right
what else I guess why do people think
it's a picture though but I feel like
Selena like got a lot of picks with
people at the event like I've just
seeing her like in a lot of pictures by
the way there was so much camera footage
so much everything like wouldn't we see
something of like Selena going over
there like I didn't see her even near
that table I don't know there's so many
tables and there's like not enough
cameras no I
know I don't know
anyways Timothy says it's all good it's
not all good it's not but thanks for
like trying to meks for trying but I I
just want you to know like if you and
Kylie did say no like you have every
right to like based on like you can't
just act however you want and then like
think there are no repercussions like
I'm sorry like you and this CRA and your
fans like really
were
nuts and sorry maybe you're not going to
get a picture because of it
yeah yeah our next story we have a
behind the scenes exclusive from our
reporter tury Lou on the ground at the
Mean Girls New York City premiere red
carpet was last night Lindy lwh hand
showed up everyone was shook but it was
star studded the stars of the movie old
and new the influencers came out the
music cuz they made like a bunch of
original music Meg the stallion was
there I think Billy eish was there no uh
uh maybe I made that up actually I
didn't see her yet but no Lindam me the
stallion Renee rap byy Phillips CU she
play Regina's mom yeah okay can we talk
about me and girls cuz like I'm actually
really excited to see it and last night
was the premiere and I did go and there
was a screening my book club was meeting
so I couldn't stay for the actual movie
and I also I didn't want to want watch a
movie like that I'm excited to see in a
dress and heels in full Glam like I like
to go to the movies like looking like a
rat so that's what I will be doing um so
I didn't see the movie which I'm sorry
like that would be so much more
interesting if I could like talk about
the movie um but I am really excited to
see the movie I think there's a lot of
really great things about the movie like
I think Renee rap is a perfect cast I'm
excited that it's a musical I love that
Tina Fay is in it I believe Lind Lohan
is the guidance counselor oh no that was
in the Walmart thing I'm I'm conflating
the two also actually maybe linday
Lohan's not in it whatever but I do want
to say like I do think a miscast and
it's not fair because I haven't seen it
yet but like I don't think byy Phillips
is a good Amy polar and I think that's
like a really important role and I think
they could have done better I'm sorry
wait till you see it you know I reserve
judgment yeah yeah like the clips the
clips that I've seen it's just like it's
cringe yeah I feel like this movie kind
of came out in stealth mode which I
appreciate like all of a sudden it's
here it's like they've been talking
about yeah bus Club another Club
premiere it's out on the 12th in three
days and I like that I I just like I
hope people don't miss it but I guess
I'm not like the most plugged I don't
turn on my TV so I don't see commercials
I'm not on Tik Tok so I don't see like
ads so maybe everyone else knows about
it and just I will say it's not
everywhere yeah and they're not really
advertising that it's a musical because
apparently people don't like musicals so
they want to get people in the theater
and then like surprise them with the
fact that it's a musical so this promo
and this marketing strategy for Mean
Girls has kind of blown open this sort
of like open secret in Hollywood is that
like when you have a musical um you
don't Market musicals as musicals unless
it's like undeniably a musical like
Hairspray you
know they don't Market it as musicals
because you're kind of it's not that
people don't like musicals it's just
that musicals have a very sort of Niche
audience and when you Market something
as musical you're really only going to
Market towards those people whereas this
movie is first of all it's Universal
like everyone can see themselves in this
movie like Mean Girls is a Timeless
story and if you were to mark it as a
musical you would be pigeon ho holding
yourself and I understand why they
didn't yeah but it's just it's G to be
shocking for some people it's G to be
shocking when Rene rap is sitting at the
table and she's
like yeah like what I really want to see
this me too and I think that'll be like
a fun outing yeah okay great so did you
see anything on the carpet that you need
to report
back no but I did see the girl who
invented when you know no words that oh
gosh sing did you talk to her no I was
like kind of nervous and she like she
didn't look like she wanted to talk to
me that's classic tury yeah but do you
want to play
no okay are you ready for our next story
yeah oh no what story four oh my God no
I'm not ready stop stop pause pause cut
okay okay action the fourth and fifth
Story are brought to you by framebridge
they make it easy and affordable to
custom frame just about anything they
are fast they ship your finished frame
directly to your house in days and their
pricing is fair and transparent it's
based simply upon the size of your piece
so you know exactly what you're going to
pay up front FRA the framing industry
has got to go it is so archaic like you
literally take your diploma to the
framing store which is is like so
annoying to have to like bring something
in and it's like $1,000 for something
halfway decent it's insane frame bridge
is one of those things I wish I thought
of myself yeah I just ordered something
from framebridge and I it been a few it
been a while since I did it and I was so
impressed once again with the ease of it
you just upload your photo you can pick
from any frame every color every type of
texture so many of our photos are
digital right upload we just took Family
Photos so I wanted to get one of them
framed and also what was so nice is they
show you what the photo phot is going to
look like in any sort of frame so you
don't have to imagine oh does this Frame
you so usually at the frames where they
give you a corner and you're like oh
does it match my picture you see you see
the whole frame and the options like I
had so many options and frames that I
never would have thought would work with
the photo wound up being best usually I
would have gone with like a white frame
if I couldn't see what it would look
like but the white was not the best
option no also like yeah you can get
something framed but what they have that
I think is really unique is they have a
popular line of curated Gallery walls so
you can like you know how Gallery walls
are so cool but who knows how to put
that together they'll do it all for you
it's so great it's so easy and you can
visit framebridge.com to custom frame
just about anything that's framebridge b
r dg.com they have a happiness guarantee
if you're not 100% happy with your piece
for any reason they will make it right
today's episode is also brought to you
about by expressvpn you know when you're
searching for something on Netflix and
you only get a fraction of what Netflix
actually has to offer they have more
than 18,000 titles globally but only
about 6,000 of those are available in
the US you are missing out on thousands
of great shows unless you're using
expressvpn an app that lets you change
your online location so you can control
where you want Netflix to think you're
located they have over a 100 different
locations so you can gain access to
thousands of new shows no matter where
you live this player works with many
other streaming services too like Disney
Plus Hulu max bbci player which is
normally only available in the UK okay
let me tell you about a time I used
Express vpm that was a really important
life-changing day when I was in the
British Virgin Islands it was the same
day that Harry and Megan did their Oprah
interview now you would think like
Royals I'm in British Virg no it was
only in the US cuz Oprah I forget what
channel was on like CBS or something uh
not me sitting on the beach using
Express VPN like
watching probably the only person in the
British Virgin Islands in Virgin Gorda
to be watching Harry and Megan on Oprah
I could do that because of expressvpn a
lot of people use expressvpn for love
Island UK because love love Island us no
offense kind of stings and love Island
UK is like an amazing show you can do
that too with Express VPN don't be
missing out on all the premium content
because your Wi-Fi is like screwing you
up check out expressvpn it's super fast
it can work work on any device it
encrypts your data so stop missing out
on great TV and get thousands of shows
with expressvpn we get them we got them
to give you guys three extra months for
free when you use our special link so go
to expressvpn.com toos that's
exp s vpn.com theeast to get three extra
months completely free thank you la I'm
so hungry what are you having for lunch
Sakara oh right oh but I don't know what
like my me my lunch meal is it's always
it's usually a bomb salad which is all I
ever really want for lunch even if I'm
not doing Sara and that's why I like
Sakara cuz it's like a nice juicy salad
that's nice I know it doesn't sound that
appetizing but if you're a salad
lover salad I actually really like salad
are you a salad lover I am like even if
I don't have to be eating a salad I like
a salad there's so much you could do
with it dress it up dress it down that's
crazy like I tolerate salads these days
I don't love them especially when I'm
pregnant like I really just crave like a
fresh juicy salad
I'm so hungry what are you going to have
for lunch I'm torn
between so there are two places by the
studio that two Road diversion of path
everybody knows tures were M two path
diversion of wood tures were mows but
there's also place I like to get a wrap
from I don't do it all the time
yesterday I did it it was
disgusting I kept like having to spit
out the lettuce it tasted like there was
plastic oh I know where you get your
wrap from they kind of have quality
control and you never know if you're
going to find a finger so like the
now I'm like I really do want the RP I
got to go to Lenny's lenwich they have
the best wraps go to lenwich there's
like not one near
me there's one nearish maybe I could
order there's one yeah you could order
why don't you place it now maybe CU I'm
just not sure like I'm just not sure I
didn't have breakfast I'm really hungry
I feel like I'm going to faint I didn't
get a chance to eat my breakfast yet
either so I get to eat my cigar
breakfast and lunch together super full
like a big part of my health Journey has
been eating breakfast I never used to
eat breakfast and I know you're going to
say like eating more is your I wasn't
going to say that no breakfast is really
the most important meal of the day it
really is it gets your metabolism
started like you can't really start your
metabolism and like burning calories
until you stoke it with breakfast no and
today was just like kind of busy in the
morning because you had like this you
had a doctor's appointment we thought we
were going to move the time like so I
was just like kind of like mulling about
I didn't like start my day and then I
was like oh I got to get dressed
and run to the studio so usually I have
a lot of people suggested uh because I
was looking for protein bars and a lot
of people suggested bebell and I have
been eating them and I just want to say
it was a good suggestion thank you so
much oh nice you know I love my GAC cros
yeah garro is good protein I mean not
per protein perfect bar is also good
yeah I sometimes have a banana sometimes
I have Cheerios and yogurt I've been
like really getting into breakfast
breakfast is hard for me CU I don't like
eggs okay you know what I usually eat
for breakfast that's very filling
oatmeal oatmeal also don't like oatmeal
love Cream of Wheat I feel like oatmeal
is a little hardier it is cream of wheat
is so good but like you like you need to
have 10 pack packets before you feel
fall yeah it's just like a liquid
oatmeal's got but it's so like putting
mug putting cream of wheat in a big mug
and like wearing a cardigan is like like
it's so cozy you got to have that dense
oatmeal I need to get cream of wheat for
my house I need to write that down okay
I'm sorry what was the fourth story
Raquel Levis is blasting Tom sandal for
playing the victim on post Scandal
podcast so raakel which we didn't even
mention came out with a podcast of her
own called Rachel goes Rogue well she
released a trailer and like the artwork
like a month ago and now she's talking
about Tom doing an interview on two te's
in a pod and she said he did yeah oh she
said I know that he's really trying to
milk the victim role to make himself
look better I think but in reality it's
making him look worse she accused him of
playing the offensive after finding out
that she was re releasing her own
podcast to share her side of the story
she shared her unfiltered opinion after
a clip from his recent appearance on two
T's and a pod was played in the short
video he claimed he was fully in love
with Rael and said it was very
heartbreak breaking that they no longer
have a relationship she admitted that
she already listened to the interview
maybe five times and made her sick to
her stomach quote I've never had this
oops hold on I've never had this
physical reaction before but I felt like
I was going to be sick cuz his voice
repulsed me and I'm like okay this is a
good sign she continued she confessed
that hearing him say he missed her and
loved her was vindicating but she still
felt like he was victim blaming it
seemed like he really did a flip on me
and he really threw me under the bus and
he was okay with it and it seemed like
he was doing a lot of victim blaming and
not taking accountability and owning up
and maybe standing up for me a little
bit she added that if he really did love
me then he probably would not say
something like that so yeah she did this
podcast she talked a lot about Tom she
also talked a lot about the dog saying
like you know standing by that like the
dog had a lot of Behavioral issues and
then James like was posting on Instagram
yesterday being like the dog is fine um
and it's just kind of crazy how like
Raquel's really the only person we
haven't heard from and I think her
perspective is probably the most unique
and the most um like she will have the
most to say yeah and also like Tom
sandal is a bold face flyer yeah so
whatever I don't know what about like
hearing her syet of the podcast like
kind of did nothing for me it's like
either like Scandal is just truly over
like it and I think it is or it's just
like I've lost flavor for this story
like I didn't care to hear Raquel when
this whole time like the only person who
I really did want to hear from was
Raquel yeah I agree with the roll out of
her response just kind of took any sort
of interest away like first she went on
first she was MIA then she did Bethany's
podast
oh yeah that was a bad call yeah and now
she has a podcast of her own which also
doesn't really sit right with me because
like if you're going to be a podcaster
then you should go back on manner pump
rules because like the two go hand inand
it will be good for your podcast and
you're still going to be in the public
ey so you don't have to worry about like
the mental health consequences of being
on the show because you're still
choosing to be in the public eye with
your podcast so and it's good for your
podcast to be on a reality show yep so I
was glad when she wasn't going back to V
PP PE cuz I was like oh she's going to
live a more private life and focus on
herself and and I think the taste of
Fame you know she it wasn't what was
best for her and she really needs like
to take a step back so now she's just
taken half a step back and I don't get
it yeah no I don't think there's been
like a lot of thoughtful strategy put
into like her quote unquote comeback or
her reaction to all this I think it's
actually been very like human I think
she's like taken her time and you know
thought what do is doing what she thinks
is best not returning to the show but
like still remaining somewhat in like I
think she's really is like she's not
planning this in any sort of like
strategic Or Meticulous way she's just
like doing what she thinks is best um
but I at this point like I'm I'm I'm I'm
settled like with Scandal like I like
I'm fine yeah at least until the show
comes back but yeah I agree she's not
being strategic nor does she need to be
or should be but if you're going to have
a podcast then yeah you need some
strategy you need PR you need listeners
like so
it's you know you got to jump in with
both feet or not yeah agreed or or not
or not yeah I was hoping for the or not
route yeah I think it would just be best
for her yeah our fifth and final story a
little
throwback okay are you ready to be
thrown
back to the Spice Girls days because
Spice Girls Melby says um she's staying
mum on the meaning of ziga zig ah lyric
from the song wanabe she said it's a
group secret so during I never thought
it meant anything me neither but during
an interview on Monday's episode of
today with hoden and Jenna she was asked
to explain the gibberish lyric from The
Spice Girl signature hit wannabe and
chose to keep its meaning to herself
claiming it's a group's secret she
co-wrote the chart topping song with her
fellow Spice Girls members well as
producers and those are the only people
she wants to know the meaning of zigazig
ah well like I'm annoyed because I never
used to sit and wonder if it meant
something I just assumed it was like
like music
things fre fre you know like I never
thought it meant anything now that I
know it does like like now I need to
know she said it's a group secret but
you can make of it what you want I made
up that word and I can't tell you if I
do I will have to kill you and we don't
want to do that we love you both
speaking of Spice Girls I just saw um
Victoria Beckham posting like a lovely
tribute to Nicola Peltz for her
birthday I thought about making it a
story but it's not enough of a story
just to say that Victoria Beckham and
her daughter-in-law are really getting
it along now by the way for other people
like it's not a story but for these two
like I am so enamored I am
like it was a perfect storm of like
their wedding Nicola and Brooklyn
becoming like this big thing then also
the Beckham documentary and people
becoming obsessed with Victoria and
David like these last couple of years
have just been really good for the
Beckham family like I'm obsessed I need
a Beckham family reality show so I'm
sorry like it is enough of a story for
me no it's enough of a story because of
what we we've been talking for years
about these two feuding these two have
been feuding like Brooklyn was so on the
outs with his family he married this
girl you cannot tell me otherwise no no
he was like you could see it cuz the way
that they're posting now they weren't
posting then yep there was a vacuum and
I'm sorry like I do think it's rude that
and maybe maybe it's not but like I
think she should have worn something
Victoria Beckham to her wedding like I
do right but we don't know that that
wasn't Victoria being like I'm not
dressing You Wench so true oh my God we
don't know like where the Discord
started but there were a few years where
like Brooklyn was not always seen with
his family or like with Nicola there was
wasn't Harmony and now there is harmony
up the Wu I don't know I feel like they
just had a family meeting and they were
like tabul laasa yeah let's try this
again because they are like a really
close family and it was sad when
Brooklyn would like loves his wife so
much but they're not with the rest of
the family who are always together and
very loving and the parents are very
loving and like it's like why would
Brooklyn have fallen out from that
1,000% it was
sad knowing like that this is what it
could have been like like m
seeing how they're acting now makes me
even more Resolute that like there was
something wrong of course no no no I
don't feel the need to prove that there
was something wrong before like it's all
the evidence is there and listen they're
human beings planning a wedding is
stressful like your families are going
to butt heads like it's it's normal and
the fact that they've bounced back in
kind of a quick turnaround I'm happy for
them I'm very happy for them it looks
like Nicola and Victoria are really
getting along and when
you get down to Brass tax they're very
similar no boys always marry girls who
remind them of their mothers like it's
so true and these two are a perfect
example of that they're just like
fashionistas like they're they're so
similar yeah no they look Alik they're
extremely Posh yep and I love like I'm
obsessed with Nichola she's one of my
favorite people to follow on Instagram I
agree and she's always posting a lot of
good content like she uses her digital
camera she takes quality photos she
dresses nice she shows us her life it's
good little lip gloss a little lipstick
thank you yeah and um for me it's enough
for her to just be like an influencer of
course she's also an actress and
director producer she has her new film
coming out which she's also promoting
but I like the beach picks with the
family me too and Christmas at
Grandma's yeah and like a lot of Selena
Gomez oh yeah she's like
a I I feel like the term third wheel is
like derogatory but like she's like
always hanging out with them I've never
heard that's derogatory I mean it makes
the person sound like a
loser
so um um maybe that's what Selena was
trying to do with Kylie and timate yeah
become like the
new even though Selena has a boyfriend
now she posted a lot of pictures with
Benny she did why wasn't he there I
don't know I'm sure she got A plus one
yeah if she wanted to
yeah yeah but they did post like a lot
of smooching pics yeah yeah so those are
the fast five stories feels so you
needed to know him I cannot wait to wrap
the show up because I've literally I'm a
bottomless pit of hunger like I've never
been so hungry in my life oh and
speaking of hunger right after this I'm
recording a solo pod which I like kind
of never do but I always like want to do
just to like try it out you know it's
like really hard that's time what you
said she said she wanted to brush up on
her solo podcasting skills because I'm
leaving Jackie for my own said why T
like why do you needan to brush up on
that because you know what there's just
like something you want to prove to
yourself that you can do yeah like it's
a challenge for for an artist like who
for someone who does this for a craft
like it's an extremely I would say it's
like a top tier level thing that only
like certain podcasters can do and I've
done it maybe twice when you were on
maternity leave the first time I did my
smut books one like I I've done like two
or three always on patreon because I
feel like that's where I can just sort
of like express myself in an honest way
and I had been asked to do a part two
about OIC so I'm going to do that and I
don't really need you for that you know
so I feel like what what's a better
episode than to brush up on my skills
maybe you want to do one too yeah I
guess guess it would be really
convenient if both of us were proficient
in Solo podcasting because that's not
why people tune in they tune in for the
for the girlies oh they turn they tune
in for this song and dance yeah but
every now and then like and I do want to
brush up on my skills I want to try it
and I have a lot to say about OIC so and
when it's like question and answer it's
very easy to do it by yourself but no
cuz imagine like every time someone
couldn't do it it was like no different
to just do it by yourself but that's not
how it works around here just imagine
right so I'm going to be doing that
today so make sure to tune in to the
patreon for that and we've
got Spirit yes we do we've got Spirit
how about you how about you hope
everyone has a great day thank you guys
so much for listening to the to mil
Morning Show where we Del with the past
five stories you need to know every Mond
through Friday on YouTube so if you're
watching this on YouTube please feel fre
to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we are also available as a
podcast anywhere podcast can be found so
Spotify iTunes Stitcher public radio i r
cast box all the places where have you
listen to podcast find USA toast leave a
five star review about a beautiful
stuning and wickedly talented we are
hope you guys have an amazing day love
you and we'll see you tomorrow love you
bye